[Musique]
l'ancien président de la république
jacques chirac est décédé ce jeudi 26
septembre à l'âge de 86 ans
une journée de deuil national a été
décrétée par emmanuel macron ce lundi le
département de la réunion a tenu à
participer à cet hommage en relançant
rire et nous avons eu en savez dans un
présent la république new kids c'est un
moment important dans l'histoire de
notre pays rapporte signé jacques chirac
parce que jacques chirac va aimer
l'outre-mer il aimait la réunion en
particulier les images de jacques chirac
entre les voies c'est un homme un
président entouré de la population lui
serrant des mains discute en dialoguant
avec les familles et ça c'est une belle
image c'est là un homme politique et
profondément humaniste et je dirais que
au delà de ça jacques chirac était un
homme authentique quand on fait de la
politique vaut pas seulement penser aux
horizons la de ce qui va se passer
l'année prochaine l'année d'après il
faut toujours penser beaucoup plus loin
et d'autres engagements il est celui-là
et jacques chirac nous l'abri nous
portons ces belles valeurs ces belles
valeurs d'humanisme d'engagement et de
volonté ou à servir cette population qui
nous entourent que l'on doit aimer que
l'on doit aimer quand on fait de la
politique non et ça jacques chirac nous
l'arbre et une exposition photo a été
mise en place et le public a pu suivre
en direct la retransmission des
commémorations nationales puis à 15h01
de silence a été respectée
[Musique]